okay we're going to interrupt that
reporter's Deputy labor leader Angela
Rayner takes to the stage at the labor
party conference let's listen in
[Applause]
welcome friends it's a pleasure to speak
to you today as your Deputy leader and
to be back in Liverpool together again
after our country has enjoyed all roles
that we lost during the pandemic and at
a time of national mourning the late
Queen stood for Unity in the darkest of
times and public duty above all else
this is her Legacy
for many
this time has been a painful reminder of
losing a loved one as too many of us did
during the pandemic
for others it's a moment to reflect
for me
I think of a lifetime of public service
and the Legacy we all leave
now our duty to the next generation is
to shape a future that is brighter than
the past
that is our task this week to set out
the future that we should face and that
should face our children
because conference I see too much lost
potential
Britain deserves better and I know we
can do better
just look at this government's record
since we last gathered in Liverpool just
four years ago
three different leaders a catalog of
sleaze waste and lies
Cummins Patterson and Pinscher back to
the hill Chris Grayling Grant chaps and
too much Matt Hancock far too much Matt
Hancock green cards and non-doms
tree houses and even tractor Pawn
breaking the law in a specific unlimited
way queues at the airports chaos at the
borders mountains of PPE unfit for use
billions in fraud written off sewage in
the rivers a prime minister hiding in a
fridge three sleeves Watchdogs out in
the cold and the Bernard Castle eye test
the Downing Street crime scene broken
swings wine stains sick on the walls
126 fines more than anywhere else in the
country rules made rules broken party
gate wallpaper gate too many gates too
little too late mates
and now a prime minister who says people
don't work hard enough well enough is
enough just as our country
just as our country was desperate for
change in 1997 we need change now
because Britain is at a Crossroads
conference
a moment of decision about what future
we all want about what we can
collectively achieve together
and about what we can be
and at this moment
what do the conservatives offer
lying in the pockets of oil and gas
Executives enriching Bankers while
families are starving attacks on our
most basic rights
be in no doubt conference they're coming
after the most basic things that we
expect decent work Fair pay the
foundations of a family life
conference so long as I have breath in
my body I will defend those rights and
including the right to strike
and when in power we will repeal the
anti-worker and anti-trade Union laws
this conservative government has enacted
all of it
Tories are not on the side of working
people in Britain today Liz truss has
already made that clearer than it's ever
been she's chosen to stun for the vested
interests for the oil companies and for
the bankers
for those profiting from this crisis and
not suffering from it
and it is working families who have been
bearing the Brunt
when I was a young mum I remember that
sick feeling in my stomach
all it takes is one break one accident
one mishap and you can't get by
and if your kids have holes in their
shoes their feet get wet on the way to
school if your fridge breaks you can't
feed your family
it's not a vision for a modern Britain
is the result of years of Tory decision
[Applause]
conference families up and down the
country this winter many for the first
time in their lives and now living on
the edge
and it's not just families that are
suffering
years of under investment have shattered
the resilience of British businesses
I think of the small business owners
like Pauline in my constituency of
Ashton who runs a local pub that doubles
as a food bank and a community center
during the pandemic Pauline had to close
her doors another small business left
out in the cold by this government
and now she's absolutely sick with worry
about her energy bills skyrocketing
feeling fear of closure yet again
local popes and businesses are the live
blood of our communities but at every
twist and turn the government poured
money into the pockets of the cronies
leaving people like Paulie in high and
dry
they need a government on their side and
instead they get Liz trust level down
Liz trickle down Liz
and so I asked Liz trust today
whose side are you on
when you boost Bankers bonuses but fast
working people to carry the can for the
energy crisis
whose side are you on
using the pandemic to power billions
into the bank accounts of cronies while
nurses while binbags whose side are you
on
when you say the working people of this
country need more graft then deprive
them of the fair pay
whose side are you on
conference I'll tell you who was on my
side when I needed it the most a labor
government was on my side when I had my
first baby and nowhere else to turn
a labor government was on my side when I
didn't have a home let alone enough
money to heat it
and a labor government was on my side
when I wanted to be a good mum to my
kids and improve their lives and I
promise you this conference that when
I'm Deputy Prime Minister a labor
government will be on your side too
I will make it my mission to spend every
penny of the public money for the good
of the nation making Britain work for
working people investing in our local
communities and talent and standing up
for this country
just as we were in 1997 we're now at a
Crossroads
the moment of choice is upon us
our movement to show our country what we
can do together
the next Labor government will pump
money back into the pockets of local
communities the people who built Britain
consider this
a third
of all government spending goes on
procurement a third
more than the NHS double the education
budget
and labor will Unleash the Power of
procurement to drive up standards and
today I'm announcing our value for money
guarantee
our pledge to ensure that every single
penny of taxpayers money provides the
best possible value to the public
we will turn the Tory procurement racket
on its head so it serves the national
interest and not the vested interests
our five-point National procurement plan
will start by rewarding businesses and
Enterprises who pay their taxes and pay
their workers properly creating
opportunities for new jobs and skills
and helping our high streets Thrive
again to unlock opportunity everywhere
and reverse the tide of young people
fast to leave their hometowns hand in
hand with Labor's green Prosperity plan
for green growth across Britain
and second we will give small Enterprise
a Level Playing Field at winning
contracts where the tour is handed
billions of pounds to their cronies with
links to tax Havens we will ensure local
businesses are no longer shunted to the
back of the queue behind Giant
corporations with more more Farm fillers
than they have workers we will cut red
tape and streamline their bidding
process giving small businesses a
genuine shot
it will no longer just be the giant
corporations with the glossiest leaflets
that wins everyone will get a fair
chance
those who put into the system
an uphold good standards will be
rewarded
and the Tories had a VIP Lane their
donors cronies you know firms with Tory
MPS on their books or anyone who could
WhatsApp Matt Hancock
we will replace that approach entirely
the only Fast Track Lane I will allow is
for local businesses and Enterprises who
create wealth in our communities and
contribute to a fairer Society the VIPs
on the labor conference will be all of
you the British public
and thirdly we will raise standards
across the economy by clawing back the
Public's money from those who fail to
deliver for taxpayers and will plow that
money back straight into a dynamic
ethical local Enterprise fund quality
and Innovation not failure will be
rewarded and by striking our failed
providers we will help local businesses
thrive
never again can we see a repeat of the
Scandal that has seen Tory ministers
write off 10 billion pounds on unused
PPE they bought with our money defective
substandard and unfit for use we'll give
the Tory sleaze Merchants their marching
orders
and instead conference we will use the
power of procurement to boost local
businesses that work for Britain
with labor they will no longer be locked
out of the system
and fourthly we will guarantee
transparency about taxpayers money and
how it's spent through a public
dashboard of government contracts it's
inspired
conference is inspired by Ukraine's
anti-corruption blueprint even under the
attack from Russia they are honest about
how they spend public money so what's
the Tories excuse they were at it again
this week refusing to come clean to the
British public and allow the spending
watchdog to assess the true damage of
the Tories discredited trickle-down
approach
there'll be no hide in places for
cronies and no corner for corruption we
will keep the receipts and we will
publish them at conference we won't stop
there
we will back the workers who are
creating Britain's wealth demanding
better for our people
which brings me on to Outsourcing
conference
the Tories have become too dependent on
handing away our Public Services on the
cheap and now we're all paying the price
we will oversee the biggest wave of
insourcing for a generation
today I can announce that before any
service is contracted out public bodies
must show that they work the work
couldn't be done better in-house and
will reinstate and strengthen the
two-tier co-creator by the last Labor
government and scrapped by the Tories to
end the scandal of outsourced workers
getting second-class pay and conditions
thank you
what conference will go further still
building on our new deal for working
people I can today unveil Labor's Fair
work standard inspired by labor and
power across the country in Wales in
London West Yorkshire the north town
greater Manchester and here in Liverpool
it will underpin a new Fair work hold
for the public sector guaranteeing Fair
conditions job security well-being
proper training rights at work and Union
access
and we will also create a fair work gold
standard to Champion the very best of
employers and the labor government will
be on the side of the self-employed too
we will give genuinely self-employed
workers the right to a written contract
and timely payment by law so they aren't
left out of pocket and chasing invoices
because our Fair work standard will
raise standards for all
and Conference
I say this to you now because labor just
doesn't have a vision for this country
we have a plan and we have a plan to
grow a fairer Greener economy we have a
plan to rebuild trust in public office
and to clean up politics
we have a plan to unleash the potential
the Tories have held back for far too
long
and the plan for Britain means we'll
rise to the occasion just like we did in
1997 because the conservatives
they've made their choice they've chosen
their side
but we are on yours and we are ready to
lead this country to better
a labor government to unite this country
through the darkest times ahead a labor
government to hand power back to the
people and the places that once powered
Britain and their labor government that
will always be on the side of working
people
the Tories have broken Britain but
together
we can rebuild it again
and make Britain work for working people
once again thank you conference
[Applause]